[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
noch heute mache das was ich nie gemacht
hat und zwar kästen bier schokolade und
vergleichen ob teure schokolade
glücklich die battle zu diesem zweck
haben wir einmal hier den konkurrenten
aus wie billig sagt er die namen
deutscher jahre alten folgen künftig
fern haben die im mittleren preissegment
diese schokolade für zwei euro und in
der absoluten premium live pralinen für
20 euro gibt wird man vielleicht sagen
ja die pralinen schokolade keine
unterschiede probleme es ist wirklich
schwierig wird europol implizit auch
schokoladen oder anderen form mittelmeer
blicken vergleichen würde und wir fangen
einfach mal an ich werde die schokolade
nach drei kriterien stellen natürlich
geschmack da wir aber auch oft die
schokolade kommt für die verpackung
herkommt und an dritter stelle
die kunden sich die schokolade selbst in
den mund zweifellos wir fangen an mit
finkenbrink und verträge julia element
mit ihrer alten vollmilch nuss
schokolade wächst das design so
verlaufen ist relativ sauber für mich
relativ klein aber mega schlicht das
könnte schon in der optik punkte
abzugeben hätte auch so gerade eben die
tafel welt ist vom design her eigentlich
ganz neu positioniert
[Musik]
änderten ja auch abends trinkt genauso
schmeckt diese tat ist so rein
geschmacklich nicht nur wird
in meinem tisch gesagt ich würde sagen
wir natürlich noch wie gut man sich
selbst nehmen und werden kann schokolade
einfach immer drei versuche und dieser
würde man die wenigen versuche braucht
jetzt gewarnt
[Musik]
hatten die drei punkte politik und die
schulnoten von 1 bis 6 schlechteste ich
würde sagen die haben nur schokolade
optik wanne drei geschmack fast schon 43
43 - beides ganz abgehakt für mich
überhaupt nicht ich habe eine vier
zimmer richte meinen und in den mund
werden gegen eigentlich gut 22 sich die
berechnet aus den einzeln und machen am
ende um den gewinner festzustellen jetzt
geht er weiter mit dem kandidaten zwar
im mittleren preissegment dafür dass
hier
ich musste ein verpackungsdesign ist zum
beispiel gar kein vergleich dass die
20.000 meine geile aus die vor allem
traurig ich leite auch zu machen
dieser hat gerade eben wirklich mal eine
ecke geile auf jeden fall das ist
deutlich kleiner und der optik her muss
mir gut überlegen welche nötig da gebe
ich will dass mein geschmack leute das
ist geschmack technisch von pollstar
weiter
24 kommt der ultimative test war wie oft
muss man werfen
dieses stellt in seiner eigenen versuch
gescheitert die stückchen größer macht
es schwieriger leute die täglich mit
inhalten verschmelzen das ist wie gut
kann man die schokolade in den mund wir
hatten die leute verkaufen wie die
schokolade davor auf das heißt dass auch
in zwei jahren auch die kathi letzten
drei bekommen
er will ich bei der optik mehr einfluss
geben und geschmack ja was soll ich
sagen
seine 11 - geht immer besser - also um
ein früheres geschmack 2+ verpackungen
und 20
und jetzt der dritte teilnehmer am
heutigen schokolade betten und der
absolute platz für die 20 euro pralinen
packungen
alles klar gewesen das ist richtig geil
aus und belegen direkt mal los rein
optisch ist natürlich die einen die
verpackung im gehirn sind fahren nicht
1000 schutzfolie dazwischen es mit ihnen
ja ich esse einfach mal die einzelnen
dinge in der mitte und kokos drin ist
[Musik]
der kaiser bindemittel war einfach außen
erdnuss probiert man das ding der 14
er war richtig geil einfach mal wichtig
klar wieso macht italien zum gleichen
schluss alkohol also jeden fall so ein
hier braucht diesen wunderschönen
kleinen kügelchen oder vanille machen
wir uns in ultimativer und zwar den lärm
und dennis k
[Musik]
als dass viele leute es gibt nach
einigen geschmack der einzelnen
verpackung und zwei in den mund werfen
ok dadurch getrieben ich kann niemals
auf dieser welt kann sich denken wenn
der gewinne wieder tennis steht berühmte
mathematiker und physiker haben
monatelang gerechnet und herauszufinden
welche der drei schokolade tatsächlich
gewonnen hat und ihr ergebnis ist
überraschend
natürlich muss nadine barth einfach
geschmack optik mäßig am besten arbeiten
kosten zehn mal so viel wie im
mittelalter schokolade und 40 mal so
viel wie die einfache schokolade
das war riskant nicht sein deswegen vom
ersten platz
ich habe niemandem empfehlen das zu
kaufen weil es zu teuer macht keinen
sinn die mittlere schokolade fast schon
erste preis leistungsverhältnis in
meinen augen ich glücklich dass entgehen
und die billigflug gerade war sie sogar
eine tragikomische sowas nochmal machen
soll und wenn ja welchen lebensmitteln
da macht es für euch jungs abonnieren
will kleines video abchecken haut kein
leute und danke an andrea der kamera und
natürlich ohne gewähr dass ich mache das
schon bald immer irgendwas